what's up everyone i'm jordan and i'm
joined by craig and matt of cold iron
studios the developer behind
aliens fire team i'm very proud of
myself i've been calling it alien
fire team all week and i actually
remembered the s this time
thank you both for joining me today oh
thank you yeah exciting to be here
you definitely you got to underscore the
s there because
there's a lot there's a lot aliens fire
teams aliens
because there's a lot of them yeah uh to
kind of like start this off so
how does this game fit into the alien
timeline like what's the story of aliens
fire team so
aliens fire team takes place in the year
2202 which is a few decades after alien
and aliens
uh the kind of movies that uh that that
really inspired us
um there has been a huge like amount of
colonial expansion
uh the outer rim is like the wild wild
west
and uh and kind of the earth governments
have sent out
battalions of marines to kind of help
patrol help to
you know deal with all the corporate
infighting all the you know
the bugs and the xenomorph outbreaks
that people are running into
and uh you and your friends play as
colonial marines on one of these ships
the uas
endeavor uh and as you're going out to
the rim you're
you get a distress call like you do uh
and
uh and you're redirected to uh lv 895
and an
orbital refinery uh outside of that so
you know a few decades after the
the movies but uh lets us kind of move
the storyline ahead
and have our own story in that universe
awesome now
obviously alien has its origins
in horror but aliens fire team seems to
be more of a
thrilling maybe even more action-focused
uh
narrative are there still elements of
horror
in the story in the gameplay or those
kind of been removed to tell
a different type of alien story oh sure
there's definitely there's definitely
horror there's definitely you know jump
scares if you look at the movies right
um alien ridley scott's alien is is like
you say it's definitely a horror movie
right uh and there have been great video
games amazing video games that
that have really worked in that genre uh
when you look at
aliens cameron the cameron esque movie
uh it is a lot more like an action movie
right it's over the top it's bombastic
but there is that horror there is that
tension and uh that really is the
experience when
uh cold iron got the chance to you know
work on an aliens game and they said
well what do you want to do
uh that's really where matt and i and
shannon and the rest of the team
really kind of zeroed in on hey let's
let's make that game that's the game
that we want to see
yeah i think fire team really nails that
that fear of being right on the edge of
control of the situation
and you know you have some turrets out
your ammo is still good
and you're you're not dead yet you have
a few extra
med packs left and then you know all
hell breaks loose and
and you're screwed and what do you do at
that point and
that's the kind of like now we're
panicked our backs against the wall and
and how do we deal with this situation
and i mean the film does that
amazingly well and we just we wanted to
make a bunch of campaigns that get put
you in that same situation
all right so i'm playing i'm panicked
there's a bunch of
aliens coming at me do i have to worry
about
friendly fire at all it depends on what
difficulty you're playing on
so yeah at higher levels of difficulty
acid does a lot more damage so you have
to worry about
even killing xenomorphs with a shotgun
up close friendly fire turns on there's
less
less user interface helpers present and
we really
like ratchet up the simulation and the
difficulty there so that means that
there's a difficulty where there's
no friendly fire but like what if what
if there are face huggers what if i
need to shoot my friend in the face and
because
if i don't kill them the feeling is
going to come out of them
um if you have a facehugger on you
you're able to
to do a little mini game to to escape
from it
and then hopefully your friend can um
can heal you up
yeah but you do have to you do have to
think about exactly
whether or not now is the right time to
shoot my friend in the face
uh when you're playing with friendly
fire it's always the right time i'm
sorry dude i'm so sorry but like look
facehugger went after you and i i just
had to pull the trigger i just had to oh
i saw a facehugger on you
but okay i shouldn't bully my friends
like all the time like what if what if
it happens to me what if i
go down is that just it for me am i out
for the mission do my friends don't have
to continue
on without me a man down in the game
uh when you go down your friends can
come over to revive you
depending on the level of difficulty uh
again
like like matt said a bunch of different
difficulty levels in the game
uh there's a count of how many times you
can go down before you're out
uh and of course that that that starts
out pretty generous pretty
pretty easy and straightforward on
casual and and standard
but uh but once you get up into harder
difficulties it could be one and done
and we've seen some gameplay now of
what it's like to fight against the
aliens it looks
terrifying they're overwhelming you
they're coming on the wall the
ceilings everywhere coming from behind i
imagine at
certain points but we haven't seen much
with the
synthetic enemies how does that change
up the combat how does that change up
the gameplay
xenomorphs are like omnipresent in the
universe right and
the reason we are super excited about
about this ip in general lets us put
things on
on the ceiling lets you deal with acid
what you do with all the
all the different xenomorph types that
we pulled from from
comics and books and the films and then
adding in something like the weyland
yutani synths
really can pull in a lot of the
narrative from those those same
sources of inspiration and we have
a cover system as well so cover system
allows you to
get out of the way of ranged enemies
like some of the xenomorphs but
definitely
gun wielding weyland-yutani sense and
all the the customization that you can
do with your different classes
allows you to kind of look at a mission
and say you know i know i'm going to be
going up against more of these
this type of enemy group so i'm gonna
change my loadouts to
deal better with cover-taking enemies or
long-range fights
or i know that there's bigger batter
synths
in this mission so i'm gonna take harder
hitting um
single target weapons rather than crowd
control xenomorph controlling weapons
i say and obviously after you've done a
mission
you're like okay if i want to replay
this mission again i kind of have a
general idea of the threats i'm going to
face but
is there any system like ahead of time
warning you it's like hey
by the way you might be facing like
these types of threats and enemies in
the next mission that you haven't tried
before or
players pretty much just going in blind
the first time they tackle
a campaign mission we we give some hints
but uh but we want players to kind of be
surprised we want players to be
be you know excited and uh and have
those moments of reveal
uh within the game so i think there are
things that that
that kind of point you in that direction
but uh but yeah there are a lot of
moments where you're like oh my god what
are we what are we fighting now
seeing some of the gameplay there are
these like
outlines to the enemies or to
interactive objects just make it like
i assume just a little bit easier to see
things in
the dark of space where if lights go out
you can't see
anything is that something you can is
that something you can
uh adjust like either make things more
noticeable or
god forbid turn those off
there's a whole slew and you know people
when when gameplay went out
we have a lot of people on twitter and
our discord that talk to us about that
um yeah and of course there's there's ui
options to turn things on or off
um higher difficulties we force it off
and yeah it's a it's it's it's a little
bit different
different kind of fear there when when
you don't see them outlined and when you
have to rely on that motion tracker
and even more so on on the rest of your
your fire team
i can see it now my friend's telling me
jordan
let's always play on the hardest
difficulty because it's mysterious and
i'm like
why why
but there are different classes uh in
this game and you've given like small
like hints and a few details
for some of the classes but can you give
us a little bit
more on that what's actually like
different for each of the classes
so at launch there are five different
classes within the game
um and uh we've talked about i think
we've talked about all of them but not
not really in depth um it's super
important that if
we're making a co-op game you want to
make a role-based co-op game you want to
make sure that
you know each of your players uh each
your characters have a different role
that
they can play in combat so whether or
not it's like the demolisher who has
shoulder mounted rockets and a big
ground pound that
like is great at clearing groups of
enemies whether or not you're playing
the technician which is kind of a
more of a crowd control where it's kind
of setting up these barriers and trying
to
make sure you're controlling the xenos
in the past they're coming at you
or whether or not you're playing the
gunner which is kind of a a
generalized role uh to to kind of do
damage across the board
and really focus in on singleton enemies
so
um and there's doc who you can probably
figure out who what his role is
and recon as well which is uh which is
another class that
uh that that that has some pretty cool
abilities as well
there's a lot of breadth of
customization within each one of those
classes
some of the people i play with we all
play technicians right you have
a hand cannon and a shotgun and a turret
but i like to play with a modified
shotgun that makes it more
i would call it long range for a shotgun
really really narrow cone really long
distance firing and then
modify my turret to be a flamethrower
turret
so put the turret right behind me and it
watches my back because my
the people i play with suck and um
and use the shotgun to watch my front
you know meanwhile other people modify
their hand cannons to have like a hand
cannon with a scope on it
and a really long targeting single
target um
um placeable turret so there's like a
lot of
wiggle room in each one of the classes
and you're not really locked into those
dps tank healer type type rpg roles so
you're speaking my language like i'm the
type of person that's like oh there's a
really
detailed like in-depth customization
system here
let me just spend 30 minutes before
every time my friends and i went to play
just
customizing new loadouts so i can come
up with new strategies in the next play
session
ah this is gonna be awesome but i mean
this sounds like a really
team based game so how do players
communicate
uh in game is it all voice chat are
there any
uh non-verbal means of communication
in the game you mentioned friendly fire
yep there you go that's the first
non-verbal
um obvious obviously um we encourage
people to get on voice chat there's also
a
system where you can point out hey
there's ammo over here or you should
target this enemy
or go this way um also emotes
obviously are our big part you got to be
able to dance on
dance on the corpse of a warrior can i
say help me
because that's that's really what i need
more than anything else
yeah if you if you if you spam the ping
button when you're down
that's all you say over and over again
perfect
[Laughter]
get me up get me up give me up i'm not
sure if anyone's asking this but what is
it like jumping into the
gauntlet of making a video game in the
alien franchise because like this is a
video game
like series that has had some pretty
popular highs but also like just
some abysmal awful
lows and so it's kind of like a little
infamous in the community it's like oh
can people like make really good aliens
games like what's it like to
jump into that fray when we when we
approach
the the the or were offered
uh to be able to make this game uh i
mean we jumped at it immediately as
as huge fans of of the movies of the
books of
of everything um we just jumped on it
and grabbed the opportunity we're like
yes we want to make this we want to make
that and i think it's set in
afterwards the the the level of
responsibility the
the what has come before and and and
what is expected of us
so um i think really in the end where
we're we're lucky enough as a studio to
be able to work on something that
that we really want to play and uh i
think
would be you know if somebody else was
making it it would also be a game that
we would really want to play and so i
think that that has given us a really
good benchmark for okay let's make it
let's make sure that we're happy with it
let's make sure that we're really
excited with it
uh and we know that it's a it's it's a
high bar we know that it's something
that is
like so dear to so many people uh and
uh and it is to us too so i we kind of
used ourselves as the
as the benchmark yeah i mean as
as fans we want to play a really really
good aliens game as well
right we wanted that experience of
waking up and cryosleep
and gathering around with a bunch of
your friends and getting your load out
together
and getting on that drop ship with your
elite fire team
and going on missions on bug hunts right
and
there wasn't there wasn't that
experience out there
and we're like well let's make that
experience at least for us very first
and then um i think every aliens fan out
there
this is something that that they've been
missing and that they're gonna get
in when we release i was a little
worried at first the way that you
started when it's like everyone kind of
hopes that they awake from kyra's sleep
i'm like is he gonna go through the plot
of alien
do people want to go through the plot of
the original alien
because i sure don't i do
it's one of those you can see our office
is nice and bright there's like
really orange bright colors um
you know we're in a really dark universe
so when we're all sitting here working
we need a lot of windows open and you
know sunlight and
fun and laughter so that was awesome uh
thank you both again for joining me
today that's unfortunately
all the time that we have and for those
of you
who are watching listening from home
stay safe out there
and for more on aliens fire team and
play for all content
stay tuned to gamespot